it's great to be joined today by Richard
Larsen who's a professor in the
engineering school at MIT he is an
expert on waiting in line and he
sometimes called dr. Q this is a topic
that's very interesting to me because
there's a lot of psychology that goes
into how lines are set up there's a lot
of differences in terms of how lines are
set up from one country to another so
let's kind of first start at the in the
most general sense how'd you first start
studying something like waiting in line
well I first first of all I hate to wait
in line myself that's one of the reasons
I like to study it but I'm an operations
researcher industrial engineer type
person here at MIT
and for many years I would teach the
mathematics and physics of queueing
which was born about a hundred years ago
in Denmark by a Danish telephone
engineer named Earl I and so I would
teach the mathematics and I got all
excited I put together the first course
at MIT graduate course on queueing and
then in the 1990s I'm buying a red bike
for my for my son and I had a terrible
queueing experience had nothing to do
with the delay he had to do with
unfairness and uh and this unfairness of
you know I bought the bike and yet 25
people after me got there their goods
before I got my bike and so I was angry
three weeks later and decided to write a
proposal to NSF National Science
Foundation they funded me so I've been
studying the psychology of queues ever
since as well as the mathematics so
let's first talk about one of the the
main queueing decisions that places with
multiple cash registers often make which
is do you allow the formation of
individual lines at each cash register
and in that case each shopper sort of
has to evaluate okay how much stuff does
each person have in their shopping cart
or whatever which one do I think is
moving the most quickly versus creating
one of those sort of winding or
serpentine waiting lines where you
simply go to the next available cash
register so question number one does the
math of it tell us which system is
optimal in terms of reducing waiting
times okay well here's here is the
interesting fact the ACK the average
waiting time in each case
assuming you jockey for queue position
so if you're in one of those multiple
lines and a server becomes idle you can
switch over and make sure that they're
they stay busy the average waiting time
is the same in both but customer
experience and customer satisfaction is
way way better for the single serpentine
line compared to the multiple line
queues and that's because customers
value fairness more more than actually
the duration of the wait so first come
first serve in the serpentine line is
now the modern thing to do and just
about everywhere except supermarkets
with large carts and somebody who can
invent a solution to that for
supermarkets with large carts would
become very wealthy very fast yeah it
seems like the serpentine line where you
just go to the next available cash
register tell or whatever the case may
be it also kind of eliminates the
halting power of one slow cashier right
because the line can continue to advance
at other registers in some sense and
that probably improves sort of the
experience for the customer I would
guess yeah that that kind of smoothes
the flow so every so many seconds or
minutes you move forward you have this
experience of making progress you're
absolutely right now the server the
cashier may be slow not because the
cashier is not as talent as the others
it may be a very difficult service that
are provided to it to a customer and the
customer may be very involved in a
complex so but you're absolutely right
that that happens
Black Friday Black Friday is probably I
mean I unless you can suggest to me
otherwise it's probably the time we're
waiting in line gets the most publicity
and it involves some people waiting in
line for hours days in some cases I
think maybe we've heard about about even
longer than that do the normal
psychological dynamics of lines apply to
something that becomes sort of a social
event like Black Friday deal getting
well my if I can use the word q-tip for
Black Friday is to buy as many things as
you can off the internet and and
therefore you could do it in your
pajamas at three o'clock in the morning
at three o'clock in the afternoon you
could have a glass of wine next to you
or a Coke or whatever so
so that's my my q-tip for Black Friday
but a lot of people go there at 4
o'clock in the morning you know they'll
have a some stores will have 5 copies of
something for a nickel apiece or a
dollar piece or something so you want to
have bragging rights and get that and it
is a celebratory type of cue for many
people so these celebratory types of
cues to be seen and to make selfies of
yourself and share them on Facebook in
such queues is is a positive experience
I'm not one of those people myself but
but many people feel that way that's for
instance why you see lines blocks long
to get the latest iPhone when what Apple
releases the latest iPhone same kind of
thing same kind of thing for rock stars
who are gonna have concerts and people
will line up in tents for three days to
get those and that's a that in itself as
a celebratory experience is there are
there examples where the sort of
unfairness of how the lines are set up
is by design and one example that I'm
thinking of is airport security where
you've got the the winding line for like
regular airport security and then you've
got a separate entrance and it's just a
straight line in if you have TSA
PreCheck now and to me that actually
seems that it is strategically prominent
unfairness to show how much more I don't
know if it's prestigious or convenient
or whatever it is to pay the seventy
five bucks for the TSA PreCheck is that
a factor that exists elsewhere as well
well full disclosure as an owner of TSA
PreCheck number yeah me too yeah I love
it
guess that preference I've often noticed
recently in airports on business type
flights that the TSA PreCheck queue is
longer than the other one yeah that'll
true I mean you could argue it's still
better because you don't have to take
your shoes off but that's sort of a
different story yeah that's right no
Disney has this too with uh you can buy
expedited tickets a little bit more and
you go to the front of the line
Starbucks and and now Dunkin Donuts have
an app on your on your cell phone where
you can call ahead they owe
is placed and you go there and you jump
the queue right to the beginning and you
know some of these things are not
perceived as unfair I don't think the
TSA PreCheck is viewed necessarily as
unfair but it depends on the context and
when if everyone has access to it so if
you're if you're in you don't have TSA
PreCheck and you have an awful queuing
experience like recently many people had
at the end of the storm in JFK in New
York that might motivate them to get it
so they they're not excluded and getting
it but if there's some kind of for
instance a bouncer at a bar might it
might let their friends in and jump the
queue just because they know them that's
kind of I think that would be viewed as
as unfair does your work also relate to
the most efficient way of getting people
out of a venue and the reason I ask is
when you look at really any sports or
concert venue that that's of any
significant size there's one way in
which people enter the building or the
facility and then afterwards it's not
that done in Reverse it's usually a
completely different exit path do you
have have you done research into that as
well in terms of the the most efficient
way of getting people out of a place no
I haven't done research on on that and
and this is an illustration of something
which is still an unsolved problem the
airlines would like to know how to
optimally load an airplane yeah right to
do it to minimize the time to get
everyone seated and built the seat belt
buckle and they haven't figured that out
they've tried lots of experiments and
now it's conflicted by the fact that you
give preference to talk about preference
first-class million frequent flyer miles
these sorts of things sure oh so loading
as well as unloading is a challenge I
have not done research on that on that
particular topic
yeah there's I mean that that's not that
it's not your area but there's so many
interesting discussions there about some
airlines testing loading from both the
rear and front door of the plane letting
everybody who's sitting in a window seat
in first followed by aisle followed by
middle followed by aisle or back to
front front to back etc
what other sort of less common ways of
organizing queues are there other than
kind of the standard ones that most
Americans would be used to well the
first of the the methods you mentioned
for loading an airplane if I were a CEO
of an airline I would try some of the
things that you suggested windows first
started at the back going front then
middle and then and then the aisle but
the problem is you've got families with
small children it's really it's complex
it's not as that's right you know I
actually read and we'll get back to the
other queueing methods just but this is
interesting I read that because there's
always some glitch no matter what system
you develop for getting on the plane
that completely random sorting ends up
actually being just as efficient as
anything else because you overall just
get a distribution of people sitting all
throughout the plane that's quite
interesting that's quite interesting
usually the plane sideboard is not
random sorting because they do it by you
know you're in group number one of
course two four six etcetera so the
question was are there other interesting
cues and other cultures yeah I mean I
know that there for example in some
large post offices in the Boston area
there's no line at all you just take a
number and stand wherever you want right
the take a number is one possibility but
is there are there other ideas that
other countries have come up with well
for instance the take a number now can
be a tap so there are some restaurants
and other services where there would be
queuing and you can join the queue as a
ghost so with the app but you you you
you want to join a queue for a
restaurant that doesn't take
reservations and the app will come back
and say well you come here in 90 minutes
and we'll have a table for you and so
but basically at the physical the
physical restaurant has it has a queue
out in front and in in a sense you
become a ghost behind the last person
then that Q and that ghost moves forward
at the same speed as the rest of the
physical queue so so there are those
things I just came back from ten days in
India the queueing behavior there is
quite a different culture and queuing in
China been to China five times Hong Kong
a few times so every you know I guess
what I say is the if you examine the
queueing behavior
a country or even in a city it's a
microcosm of the larger culture from
which those people are bored where they
live and they work etc yeah obviously
you know you're you're not saying any of
this but I've have some experience
queuing in Israel and it's crazy I mean
there's no there's really no other way
to explain it and every indication is
that that it's definitely connected to
the culture I've been told although I've
not experienced that the queues in both
India and China also are not
particularly organized is that fair to
say in in India it's often survival of
the fittest know if there's a there's a
half a ditch between you and the person
in front of you the the the person is
trying to squeeze in will view that as a
big space and it happens to be whether
it's a human human or cars or jitneys or
rickshaws or what-have-you but the I
think the British stand up one extreme
they say a proper British gentleman if
he gets to a place and there's nobody
else there we'll start or start a queue
of one you know maquila blood and I have
a photograph from a from a London
newspaper the last riots they had there
which are several years ago
you see 13 looters queued up first-come
first-serve outside of a store to get
into and they let one cute one looter in
at a time it's very party and then the
next lunar goes in I mean only I think
in England what I experienced something
like this I didn't experience it I saw
it no you weren't one of the looters of
course no that last thing I want to
touch on there has to be enforcement of
whatever system you have by the business
right and this is a problem that for a
while us-based airlines were dealing
with which was that American had
boarding by zone and JetBlue had reverse
order boarding by row or whatever the
case may be
but people would ignore it and just
crowd the gate and there it is the it's
it's imperative that whoever is running
the line stick to the rules right that
is correct and I've seen this more more
and more frequently recently somebody
who's in group six tries to go up in
Group four and they scan there
their boarding pass whether it's
electronic on there or paper yeah they
said I'm sorry you have to wait for
group six oh I've seen more and more of
that enforcement recently if you don't
have that enforcement you're gonna get
chaos and chaos can sometimes lead to
queue rage and queue rage can lead to
injury and we don't want to go there
that's right if if people don't follow
the rules
it's anarchy and we just can't have that
that would not be good for anybody we've
been speaking with Professor Richard
Larson from MIT known in some circles as
dr. Q thanks a lot for talking to us
about this okay it was great okay thank
you David
why